how's everybody doing today this is
gonna be a very different video I
usually do not do announcement videos or
update videos or anything like that but
this is kind of important this is
something that's happened me recently
that I feel is definitely worth sharing
it's a very interesting string of events
that began when I purchased Roger
Ebert's life itself memoirs then I saw
that my 22 Jump Street review was
actually featured on Roger Ebert calm
after crying in the corner and holding
myself and telling me everything was
gonna be okay
I realized how excited I was about that
but if you guys don't know his new film
is coming out life itself it's a
documentary about him about his life
it's directed by the man who made hoop
dreams which many consider to be one of
the best documentaries ever made Roger
Ebert com actually got in contact with
me I know they actually wanted me to
tell you guys about something pretty
awesome that I'm gonna be taking place
in that all of you can be taking place
on this Wednesday June 18th is Roger
Ebert's birthday there's gonna be a live
Google hangout with a lot of different
critics this is all being set up by Chaz
Ebert herself Roger Ebert's wife I'm
gonna be taking part in this hangout as
well as some other really well renowned
critics who are working on Roger Ebert
com we're gonna celebrate Roger Ebert's
life we're gonna talk about the movie
life itself and here's the kicker I've
been asked to let you guys know that
tickets are gonna be given away for the
premiere of life itself in Los Angeles
Chicago and New York and all you got to
do is watch the show I would love if one
of you guys won the tickets that would
be so great I'm hoping that one of you
do I have left the preordained link for
the Google+ Hangout in the description
of this video so I hope you guys check
that out right now
get yourself situated let him know
you're gonna be there because I'm
extremely excited about it I hope you
guys are too I'm gonna be they're gonna
be talking all these people it's gonna
be amazing and I can't wait to bring you
guys my review of life itself when I
actually do get to see the documentary
because I'm really pumped to do that as
well as always guys thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes